[Music]
speaking of uh tesla cameras oh wow
what's that sensory mode all a tesla
camera tesla cameras yeah tesla camera
saves an owner's life after capturing a
man
with a knife
i know i know i need to pull this
where's this la the [ __ ] crime's
going crazy nuts dude yeah ellie only
has there are helicopters i saw you your
ig story is actually that was videos
coming out of l.a right now
where was that most recent oh no i saw
the beverly hills i don't know it's not
though in the house we have a friend
here that works for the sheriff's
department
and he would submit like pretty much
like close cases
hard evidence everything send them in
and the da comes back nope not
prosecuting this guy nope not
prosecuting this guy what's the thought
process of not i think it's like an
extreme version of virtue signaling
where like these guys they're pretty
much career politicians right so i think
what they're trying to be on on the side
of like oh you know these guys are just
misunderstood they're just product of
like this bad system so we got to give
them second chances and so because of
that when these guys get locked up like
the police are doing their job they they
take them to jail but then since the da
doesn't prosecute they just get released
and so now you're having like this
repeat pattern of like they're like
nothing happened yeah i'ma [ __ ] check
more [ __ ] jack more and more and more
and more and it's yeah it's just crazy
melrose is nuts right now dude people
just walking up that's [ __ ] up man
broad daylight the la mvp's name is
gascon he's really cool
beauty and the beast all right here we
go
and uh so this is uh right outside of a
tesla cam this person uh who is inside
the car ended up filming and posting
this social media
right before we were about to get out
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
what is he saying so you're trying to
probably trying to say something like oh
something wrong with your car in the
front or something you know like
that homeless [ __ ] where you got a
[ __ ]
uh you got to stay sharp out here man
this will stand sharp for sure
oh because with the camera you can
actually see yeah yeah you got cameras
so you literally are seeing the sport i
wonder what he would do if you just pull
the gun out
at him like this yeah doesn't that make
you want to get a good he'd call the
cops
so what made him walk away they finally
like signaled them away yeah probably
just didn't open i would assume that if
his fool's got a knife ready the second
you like pull down a window or open the
car door or something like that it's
like game on it's like give me your card
in your wallet
i'm assuming this guy's not trying to
like steal a car or anything i don't
know why i'm making that assumption but
like foreign yeah it's probably just
like petty stuff trying to stay under
the radar just give me something that
you can you know afford to get rid of
probably just carved his name and his
girlfriend's name in a tree or something
that's true you know i should have i
should have assumed that he was going to
help him peel a carrot
oh you got a fruit i could yeah he was
like hey hey you
you i'm i'm bored you got any carrots
icons
you sold me a cupcake they said it cuts
penny give me like 50 cents i'll [ __ ]
peel the potato first i heard this
epidemic about people that aren't
circumcised
that sentence i'm bored you got a carrot
[Laughter]
so this driver going by the name of
cedric from richmond virginia posted a
clip on his tick tock account last week
after experience i was in virginia
encounter with an armed man
so like like we obviously see right um
oh this guy says uh it happened on
campus got shook for a while called the
police after this so
really it's it's you see it just like
we're talking about whether it be
melrose la in general san francisco yeah
for sure
yeah man i guess if anything is a great
tesla commercial thank goodness for
cameras and all thanks tesla
it's been a while though dude this the
videos that are coming out like
it's just now i've been seeing videos of
uh
people shooting
uh while getting jacked lots of broad
daylight [ __ ] yeah daylight and now
there's more videos circulating so i
feel like more people are getting ideas
yeah yeah yeah right no but there's also
i mean there's also self-defense or like
maybe not self-defense but revenge kind
of stuff too yeah like i saw this one in
oc recently the
the dude was getting his car jacked and
or like broken into and then he just
went out to the driveway he opened up
the door and blasted the dude they ran
out yeah and then he chased him
because once you when he's running away
and you chase him and start smoking them
that's different there's that other guy
in um philadelphia who was uh coming
home bringing food into the house he's
an uber driver or whatever and then a
bunch of dudes
basically ran up to him in the driveway
i saw that they didn't know he had a gun
they were super aggressive toward him
three guys
and then they're screaming oh no please
that always happens by the way
yeah they stick a gun into someone's
face they're like give me all your money
whatever ha ha and then they get shot
and they're like oh i don't want to die
so funny yeah it's so it's it's the
irony ridiculous dude it's like you were
willing to stick a gun in someone's face
and rob them and then when a bullet hits
you you go oh mama please it
saw that i saw this video of um so you
know like the police in la they're like
super understaffed and underfunded right
now and so they're replacing like police
presence on the metro with i guess
safety ambassadors is what they're
calling it but then now that the like
homeless population saw that
at night the metro every seat is just
filled with people sleeping as the metro
just goes back and forth from one side
to the other what can the safety
metro officer do no they can't do
nothing yeah they got
yeah they can't do anything ambassading
i don't know
i don't know what they're doing i mean
people wanted to experiment with the
defund the police and and this is what
you know this is what just happens it's
crazy it's i don't know it's weird i
just feel lucky that like
i'm armed i'm young i can protect myself
all this stuff but what about the people
that can't like what about the poor old
grandmas that have to take buses and
they don't got a gun and they don't know
what to do like especially asian grandma
they like to walk and stuff yeah yeah
because people always talk about oh he
just learned self defense and i'm like
tell that to a [ __ ] 80 year old man
on a [ __ ] oxygen tank dude like what
are you talking about you [ __ ] morons
only thinking about themselves like oh
you just gotta run you just gotta do
this and i'm like shut the [ __ ] up it
doesn't help anybody no what about the
mom with like three kids and then like
there's a crazy dude trying to bite them
all like
what is she supposed to do it's like
i don't know people just don't know
danger they've been doing like smash and
grab jobs at the slots and swap me too
at the swapping at the jewelry store at
the swampy yeah [ __ ] up sf and uh
people broke in like louis vuittons and
stuff like that but they've been doing
smash and grabs there for like a long
time my car got broken and dude i was at
a show like a like a regular civilian
car or a van yeah uh not the van dude
the van would have sucked but now it was
a just like a toyota rav4 yeah i came
out from the show and like the window
was gone i knew already and i actually
had my luggage in the car like in the
trunk oh yeah man they took it off so
you lost all that [ __ ] that [ __ ]
happened to [ __ ] our very own beach
mom in san francisco [ __ ] up yeah sf i
think is the worst in the country of
smash and grabs but is it sf or is it
oakland like is it like because like
when i'm in sf right it's a bunch of
like
tech folks and like rich people and i'm
like so that's who you want to hit
though if you're trying to ride
that's what i'm saying like
it's not locals is it you know what i
mean like i don't know well yeah they
announced it saying that it wasn't right
yeah they were saying so it's like
people coming in yeah
so compact in san francisco yeah you
could probably hit a bunch of cars i
think they're doing multiple yeah yeah
like beverly hills like people getting
[ __ ] up on rodale drive all that like
it's not people in beverly hills it's
like people coming through
there's were the rich people same with
melrose like if you go to melrose at
night there's nobody there like it's not
like those are local people that [ __ ]
live there causing problems but that's
why it's broad daylight [ __ ] yeah cause
that's when people are there that video
of the couple eating uh at a restaurant
yeah and the guy had an extendo mag did
you see that yeah that's crazy a lot of
people were saying that it was like a
inside job or someone probably set them
up or something i don't know man
it feels like there's a lot of inside
[ __ ] on melrose because even one time i
was there with a friend we went into
this store and you know when you go in
the stores you got to give your backpack
or something and they put it on a shelf
and we gave it to the dude and he puts
it so this shelf is pretty much spans
the whole store and he puts it right at
the front most part of the shelf and
then he [ __ ] magically takes a break
right when he takes a break another dude
came in grabbed it stole it and then he
came right back out
yeah and then he was like oh man
somebody took it and like all the [ __ ]
in the
the store was even like
right when you left
and then um we didn't realize it but me
and my friend were like recording a
stupid video in the store and in the
[ __ ] background we saw the guy
[ __ ] running and taking it
yeah did you get them in the video yeah
and this the store surveillance got it
too and it was like clockwork the guy
puts on the show [ __ ] minds his own
business goes to the takes a break in
the back yeah like and then a dude just
walks right in just takes it and she had
her laptop her camera like and a nice
camera her lens like all this great [ __ ]
in there and just gone what do you think
would have happened if
if you suspected that right and then you
go oh can you show me
like where did you do in the back and
then you go in the back and you [ __ ]
this [ __ ] up and then you locked the
door and you said you're gonna call your
friend right now and we're gonna bring
this [ __ ] back or else i'm gonna keep
torturing you
that's g i like that
i like the way you think bro
that's like my face because that's one
of my fantasies oh my god i want to do
it so bad i was like i wish i was with
you ryan
they'll be like we're gonna close that
door i'm gonna call a couple friends and
we're not gonna leave until this is
settled it did say a wave of organized
theft and smash and grab robberies have
been hit in california's bay area this
month and it said even like
approximately 80 people raided the
nordstrom walnut creek stealing
merchandise in under one minute so
they're like three employees were kicked
punched pepper sprayed spokesperson are
saying like
over a billion dollars worth of goods
were stolen from bay area stores this
month in smash and grab robberies from
like louis vuitton nordstrom burberry
bloomingdale's walgreens lululemon blah
blah a billion think about the organized
theft game of smashing you know what
sucks so like the amount of money it
costs a lot of these like baller stores
now they're hiring private security but
all these guys are like 50 100 an hour
so the amount of money they're spending
on private security is way more had they
had police presence there yeah and they
have less jurisdiction you know yeah and
if there's no like repercussions for it
why would they stop doing it i mean like
when it comes down to this kind of crime
though like
if if smashing grabs burglaries or
whatever like and they just need money
or whatever the reason is um i just hope
that like violent
holdups and like armed robberies and
like actually like
shooting someone
and taking their money like i hope that
that [ __ ] doesn't happen you know like
smashing grabs and like burglaries like
i think it's like
kevin nishida
a security guard protecting a news crew
covering retail theft in oakland died
this weekend after being shot during a
robbery attempt
he's a security guard i think he was a
former former cop
retired cop became an armed security
guard for news crews and then like i
think they all got like robbed and then
never got shot yeah i've been seeing a
lot of videos across the internet
of there was one there was a former cop
and i think it was in oakland he was
pumping gas
and three guys came out and they tried
to rob him and he was like kind of like
talking about them and exchanging with
them and then as they go out he pulls
out a gun because he was strapped took
out one of the guys he got shot in the
shoulder and then two guys got away but
it's just so crazy like all this isn't a
[ __ ] gas station like everywhere
every setting it could happen at any
time so you have to keep your head on a
swivel i guess but most of it's
happening in like california because if
people are getting off you know that's
so crazy
[Music]
you